David Green borrowed $600 in 1970 to
open a business that led to the first
Hobby Lobby store today the
arts-and-crafts retail chain has 780
stores 35,000 employees and more than
four billion dollars in sales Hobby
Lobby won a landmark Supreme Court case
in 2014
Green pushed back against part of the
Affordable Care Act the court ruled that
religious business owners are not
required to pay for certain
contraceptives for female employees
Green discusses the case and its
company's legacy in the new book giving
it all away and getting all back again
the way of living generously david green
welcome thank you so tell us exactly
what you think the message of your life
is well hopefully it's about values
wealth is more than just money it's
about values and so we want to make sure
our family carries down values and
that's why we've actually come up with a
hard copy of who and what we are as a
family the green family and it's about
mission vision and our values and so we
want to carry that down from generation
to generation to have a legacy that
exceeds us by many generations and what
too bothered you about the Affordable
Care Act well it was obvious that we
couldn't it would go against our
conscience to take life we believe that
if we supplied for drugs that were being
required by us that we would actually be
committing abortion and this is
something our family just could not do
what were those drugs there was for
drugs that I'm not insure exactly the
names of them but we provide 16
different contraceptives but there's for
after pregnancy that we feel like could
abort and so we could not do that
what about critics who say it's not a
Boxes role to determine what kind of
contraceptive coverage a woman it's
really not the government's right to
interfere with my conscience and so as
his employees or as owners my wife and I
that started this business the
government shouldn't be imposing
restriction on us that would cost us as
much as 1.3 million dollars a day if we
didn't follow what they would ask us to
do
since you won in the Supreme Court if
you work at Hobby Lobby it does not
cover contraceptive care that's correct
it does yes the 16 contraceptives we do
supply but not these four that would be
after the fact there was some research
that said that hobby lobby's 401k plan
invests in certain pharmaceuticals that
presume that that develop those very
drugs that you're opposed to is that
hypocritical no it's not hypocritical
because it'd be like me going into a
drug store and I'm seeing things in
there that I wouldn't buy but I still
have to be part of that but it would be
a very very very small percent of
anybody's 401 and if I didn't offer
different things other than one that
would be a pure 401 then I would get
tremendous criticism that I'm I'm
cutting my employees investments down to
suit me you pay about double the federal
minimum wage to your employees correct
that's correct our minimum wage is
fifteen dollars and seventy cents for
our full-time employees so how would you
feel about the government enacting
legislation that requires the federal
minimum wage to be fifteen dollars I
don't think that would be fair I think
that would be that needs to be up to the
very businesses and I think that they
want to pay five dollars an hour that's
okay with you well you cannot do that
because of the competition you cannot
hire people at five dollars an hour so
there's certain amount of competition
out there as well as a lot of young
people wouldn't have job was the
competition led you to pay fifteen
dollars no no it wasn't but we decided
to do this on our own but we certainly
couldn't pay $5.00 yeah it was a you
wanted it to be a market based decision
that the employer could make the choice
and look you're gonna recruit better and
retain better exactly by paying and that
was a decision there but we're not
suggesting the government comes in and
requires this make you a libertarian
possibly to some extent and thinking
they're too much government interference
in our life without a in question and
certainly in when it comes to religious
liberties I think they need to give us a
little more rope in that area let me ask
you about your book because you write
work is not a curse it is our calling
that's right we feel like that God owns
our business and that we're only
stewards and so our job is to do the
very best we can for our employees
that's why we're only Oh
in 66 hours we think that family is
important and that's why we talk about
in the book the values of family and the
family it should have values and of
course that's what brought us to the
lawsuit is that we have values that we
don't want to cross do you feel like
that you know that people in this
country respect the kinds of value you
have and would like to see more of it I
asked that because sometimes people
believe that there's some contempt from
elites and all of that against people
who stand up what they believe with that
religious right I think that's true but
that really doesn't waver us at all this
is what we believe we believe and we've
tried to our values is based on God's
Word and that's where we get our values
and that's something that's solid in our
culture today their values it's all over
the place
but we have something that we feel like
we can stop that and stand firmly on and
that's why we're putting a world-class
Bible Museum in in Washington DC
David Cassie quickly - we were just
talking about Apple redesigning their
stores and at the same time there's been
this question about the death of retail
how is retail how are your stores doing
well we're in a business that we're not
as affected that as much we have
e-commerce as well and we do this but
art sales have been up every year same
stores for probably 15 years fascinating
story about family business and big
success David Green Congrats on the new
book giving it all away and getting it
all back again is on sale now